WELCOME BACK TO "STATE OF THE
UNION."
WHILE DEMOATS IN WASHINGTON
TUSSLE OVER THEIR PRIORITIES AND
THEIR STRATEGY TO SS PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S AGDA, MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS AROUND THE COUNTRY ARE
FOCUSED ON EMPTY SHELVES AND
STICKER SHOCK WONDERING WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION CAN DO TO FIX IT.
JOINING ME NOW IS TRANSPORTATION
SECRETARY PETE BUTTIGIEG.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING ME
THIS MORNING, SIR.
WE'LL GET TO THOSE SUPPLY
PROBLEMS IN A MINUTE, BUT FIRST,
PRESIDENT BIDEN REALLY RAISED
THE STAKES THIS WEEK WHEN HE
WENT TO CAPITOL HILL, HE URGED
CONGRESS TO PASS HIS AGENDA.
HE EXPLICITLY SAID THE FATE OF
HIS PRESIDENCY HANGS IN THE
BALANCE, AND YET DEMOCRATS
COULDN'T DELIVER.
SO WHY WASN'T HE ABLE TO CLOSE
THE DEAL WITH HIS OWN PARTY?
>> WELL LOOK, WE ARE THE CLOSEST
THAT WE'VE EVER BEEN AND THE
PRESIDENT IS CONFIDENT THAT THIS
FRAMEWORK THAT WE'RE PUTTING
FORWARD CAN PASS THE HOUSE AND
SENATE AND GET TO HIS DESK FOR
SIGNATURE.
THE REASON YOU HEAR THIS SENSE
OF URGENCY ON HIS PART IS NOT
JUST POLITICS.
IT'S THAT THE COUNTRY NEEDS
THIS.
WORLD LEADERS ARE GATHERING IN
GAS GAO RIGHT NOW LOOKING AT
THIS CHANCE THAT WE HAVE, AND
IT'S BARELY WITHIN OUR GRASP NOW
TO BE ABLE TO BEAT THE WORST
EFFECTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE, THAT
MEANS IMMEDIATE ACTION AND
THAT'S PART OF WHAT'S IN THIS
PACKAGE BUT ALSO FAMILIES ARE
READY FOR THE SUPPORT THAT HAS
BEEN LACKING FOR A LONG TIME IN
THIS COUNTRY, TO FINALLY HAVE
PRESCHOOL FOR EVERY 3 AND
4-YEAR-OLD KID IN THIS COUNTRY
TO EXTEND THAT TAX CUT, THAT TAX
CREDIT, WHICH MEANS HUNDREDS OR
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN THE
POCKETS OF NINE OUT OF TEN
FAMILIES WITH KIDS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
THE URGENCY OF MAKING SURE THAT
WE MAKE IT EASIER TO HAVE A
LOVED ONE WHO NEEDS HOME CARE BY
CUTTING THOSE WAIT LISTS AND
TALKING ABOUT THINGS THAT ARE
GOING TO MAKE A REAL CONCRETE
AND URGENTLY NEEDED IMPACT IN
AMERICAN LIVES NOT TO MENTION OF
COURSE ALL THE TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE OPPORTUNITIES
THAT I'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT ALL
YEAR, THAT WE HAVE A CHANCE TO
DELIVER RIGHT NOW.
>> SO YOU TALKED ABOUT A LOT OF
BIG CHANGES THAT ARE CURRENTLY
STILL IN THIS FRAMEWORK
COMPROMISE.
THERE IS SOMETHING THAT ISN'T,
AND THAT IS PAID FAMILY LEAVE.
YOU RETURN FROM PATERNITY LEAVE
AFTER WELCOMING YOUR NEWBORN
TWINS, PENELOPE AND JOSEPH.
I WANT OUR VIEWERS TO HEAR WHAT
YOU SAID ON THE SHOW TWO WEEKS
AGO ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF PAID
FAMILY LEAVE.
>> I CAMPAIGNED ON THAT, SO DID
THE PRESIDENT.
THE BUILD BACK BET EAR GEN DA
INCLUDES PROVISIONS FOR PAID
FAMILY LEAVE.
IT IS LONG PAST TIME TO MAKE IT
POSSIBLE FOR EVERY AMERICAN
MOTHER AND FATHER TO TAKE CARE
OF THEIR CHILDREN WHEN A NEW
CHILD ARRIVES IN THE FAMILY.
>> WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THE MORE
THAN 100 MILLION AMERICANS WHO
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO THE KIND OF
PAID FAMILY LEAVE YOU JUST
BENEFITED FROM AND DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY THE
ADMINISTRATION DIDN'T FIGHT
HARDER TO KEEP IT IN THE BILL?
>> WELL, IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
BELIEVE IN.
I BELIEVE IN IT.
OBVIOUSLY IT'S PERSONAL FOR ME.
IT'S THE SAME TRUE FOR THE
PRESIDENT, AND IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE'LL CONTINUE PUSHING FOR.
LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT IS IN THIS
BILL.
CHILD CARE CREDIT, SUPPORT,
FINANCIAL SUPPORT FOR MILLIONS
OF AMERICAN FAMILIES TO BE ABLE
TO GET CHILD CARE, IN ADDITION
TO FREE PRESCHOOL FOR 3 AND
4-YEAR-OLDS, IN ADDITION TO THAT
CHILD TAX CREDIT THAT AGAIN IS
CONCRETELY NEEDING HUNDREDS OF
DOLLARS A MONTH.
>> NOT TAKING ANYTHING AWAY FROM
YOU BUT WHEN YOU SAY YOU WILL
CONTINUE TO KEEP FIGHTING, HOW
DO YOU REALISTICALLY DO THAT,
ENTERING AN ELECTION YEAR AND
THIS WAS THE VEHICLE ON WHICH
THE DEMOCRATS REALLY FELT WAS
THE MOST IMPORTANT, MAYBE THE
LAST CHANCE TO DO IT IN THE NEAR
FUTURE?
>> WELL, I TELL YOU HOW WE'RE
GOING TO DO IT.
WE'LL DO IT FROM A POSITION OF
STRENGTH, BECAUSE WHEN WE PASS
THIS BILL, WE WILL HAVE
DELIVERED THE MOST IMPORTANT
PRO-FAMILY LEGISLATION OF MY
LIFE TIME.
THE BIGGEST EXPANSION IN HEALTH
CARE SINCE THE ACA ITSELF, THE
MOST WE'VE DONE ON CLIMATE
CHANGE EVER AND CONCRETE
IMPROVEMENTS, LITERALLY, IN
ROADS, BRIDGES, PORTS, AIRPORTS
AND SO MUCH MORE.
WHEN YOU HAVE A SUCCESSFUL
POLICY, WHEN YOU DELIVER MAJOR
POSITIVE TRANSFORMATIONAL CHANGE
IN THE LIVES OF AMERICANS, YOU
ARE REWARDED WITH MORE RUNNING
ROOM TO DO MORE GREAT THINGS.
I FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT, THAT IDEA
THAT GOOD POLICY IS GOOD
POLITICS, AND THIS FRAMEWORK IS
GOOD POLICY.
>> YOU KNOW WHY IT WAS DROPPED,
IT'S BECAUSE SENATOR JOE MANCHIN
SIMPLY DOES NOT THINK THAT MONEY
SHOULD BE SPENT ON THIS IN THE
WAY IT WAS PROPOSED.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO HIM?
>> WELL, LOOK, AGAIN, I'M A BIG
BELIEVER IN THIS POLICY, AND I
THINK IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO
DO.
I'M ALSO A HUGE BELIEVER IN THE
THINGS THAT ARE IN THIS BILL IN
FRONT OF US RIGHT NOW.
THIS IS NOT HALF A LOAF.
THIS IS A FEAST OF GOOD
POLICIES, SOME OF WHICH MY PARTY
HAS BEEN TALKING ABOUT, OR EVEN
POLITICIANS ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
FOR LITERALLY AS LONG AS I HAVE
BEEN ALIVE AND THE CHANCE TO
DELIVER IT IS NOW WITHIN OUR
GRASP.
IT IS AN EXTRAORDINARY PACKAGE
THAT IS GOING TO MAKE CONCRETE
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE LIVES OF
EVERY AMERICAN AND I CAN'T BAIT
TO SEE IT DONE.
OBVIOUSLY, WHEN YOU PUT TOGETHER
SOMETHING THIS BIG AND THIS
COMPLEX, NOBODY GETS EVERYTHING
THAT THEY WANT.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN CLEAR
ABOUT THAT, I DON'T THINK
ANYBODY CRAFTING THEIR PERFECT
PACKAGE IN THEIR MIND WOULD SEE
IT REFLECTED HERE, BECAUSE THIS
REFLECTS THE INPUT OF SO MANY
DIFFERENT PEOPLE, INCLUDING
BIPARTISAN WORK ON THE
INFRASTRUCTURE SIDE, AND A VERY
IDEOLOGICALLY DIVERSE BIG TENT
PARTY ON THE FAMILY STUFF.
BY THE WAY ON THE FAMILY STUFF,
I HAVE TO SAY, I DON'T WANT TO
LET REPUBLICANS OFF THE HOOK.
I THINK AT LEAST SOME SHOULD BE
ABLE TO VOTE FOR THE TAX CUTS
FOR MIDDLE CLASS FAMILIES.
SOME REPUBLICANS SHOULD BE
WILLING TO VOTE FOR 3 AND
4-YEAR-OLDS TO GET PRESCHOOL IN
THIS COUNTRY, SOME REPUBLICANS
SHOULD BE PREPARED TO VOTE FOR
AMERICANS TO GET UP TO A $10
12,500 DISCOUNT ON ELECTRIC
VEHICLES TO CREATE AMERICAN JOBS
AND BEAT CLIMATE CHANGE.
EVERYBODY SHOULD BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION.
>> THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION DID
PASS 12 WEEKS OF FAMILY LEAVE
FOR FEDERAL EMPLOYEES BUT I WANT
TO MOVE ON BECAUSE YOU MENTIONED
INFRASTRUCTURE.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE SUPPLY
CHAIN CRISIS.
TWO WEEKS AFTER THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION ANNOUNCED THAT
KEY PORTS WOULD MOVE TO 24/7
OPERATIONS, SUPPLY CHAIN
BACKLOGS ARE STILL REALLY NOT
GETTING MUCH BETTER.
THERE ARE PERSISTENT TRUCK
DRIVER SHORTAGES, WAREHOUSES ARE
OVERFLOWING AND ESTIMATED $24
BILLION WORTH OF GOODS ARE STUCK
WAITING TO GO THROUGH U.S.
PORTS.
SO HOW ARE THESE GOING TO BE
FIXED AND DO YOU EXPECT THESE
PERSISTENT DELAYS TO CONTINUE
THROUGH THE HOLIDAYS?
>> WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
SEE CHALLENGES.
THE STEPS THAT WE'RE TAKING ARE
MAKING A DIFFERENCE BUT THINK
ABOUT ALL OF THE THINGS THAT
HAVE TO HAPPEN TO GET A PRODUCT
TO A SHELF ON TIME.
FUNDAMENTALLY, IT'S UP TO THE
PRODUCERS, THE SHIPPERS, AND THE
RETAILERS, AND WE'RE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO HELP THEM
MOVE THOSE GOODS ACROSS THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S OFTEN
OUTDATED.
LOOK, WE'VE GOT DEMAND THAT'S
OFF THE CHARTS.
THE RETAIL FEDERATION IS
PREDICTING AN ALL-TIME RECORD
HIGH IN TERMS OF SALES.
WE'VE GOT SUPPLIES WHICH IS IN
SOME CASES UP BUT NOT UP ENOUGH
TO KEEP UP WITH THAT DEMAND AND
THEN THE BIGGEST THING OF ALL,
OF COURSE, YOU HAVE THE
PANDEMIC.
THE PANDEMIC IS POKING HOLES IN
SUPPLY NO MATTER HOW GOOD ANY
COMPANY OR ANY ADMINISTRATION
IS, WE'RE GOING TO KEEP WORKING
ON THINGS LIKE THE PORT ISSUE,
SMOOTHING OUT ANYTHING ELSE THAT
IS WITHIN OUR CONTROL BUT THE
ONLY WAY WE CAN PUT DISRUPTIONS
BEHIND US IS TO PUT THE PANDEMIC
IN THE REAR VIEW MIRROR, WHY THE
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN LEADING
DECISIVELY TO DO JUST THAT.
>> I WANT TO ASK BEFORE I LET
YOU GO ABOUT A FLIGHT ATTENDANT
FOR AMERICAN AIRLINES WHO WAS
HOSPITALIZED THIS WEEK WITH A
BROKEN BONE, SEVERAL OF THEM IN
HER FACE AFTER A PASSENGER
ASSAULTED HER MID FLIGHT.
SO FAR THIS YEAR THE FAA IS
INVESTIGATING MORE THAN 900
INCIDENTS OF VIOLENT OR UNRULY
PASSENGERS, AND THAT'S UP FROM
150 TWO YEARS AGO.
SHOULD THERE BE A FEDERAL NO PLY
LIST FOR PEOPLE WHO BEHAVE LIKE
THIS ON U.S. FLIGHTS?
>> I THINK THAT SHOULD BE ON THE
TABLE.
LOOK, IT IS COMPLETELY
UNACCEPTABLE TO MISTREAT, ABUSE
OR EVEN DISRESPECT FLIGHT CREWS.
THESE FLIGHT ATTENDANTS HAVE
BEEN ON THE FRONT LINES OF THE
PANDEMIC, FROM DAY ONE.
AND THEY'RE UP THERE AS THE
ANNOUNCEMENT ALWAYS SAYS, FOR
YOUR SAFETY.
THERE IS ABSOLUTELY NO EXCUSE
FOR THIS KIND OF TREATMENT OF
FLIGHT CREWS IN THE AIR OR ANY
OF THE ESSENTIAL WORKERS FROM
BUS DRIVERS TO AIR CREWS, WHO
GET PEOPLE TO WHERE THEY NEED TO
BE.
THE FAA STANDS STRONGLY WITH
FLIGHT CREWS, THAT'S WHY YOU'RE
SEEING SOME HARSH PENALTIES AND
FINES BEING PROPOSED AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT ALL OPTIONS
TO MAKE SURE THAT FLIGHT CREWS
AND PASSENGERS ARE SAFE.
>> BEFORE I LET YOU GO, IT IS
HALLOWEEN.
DO THE TWINS HAVE A COSTUME OR
COSTUMES?
>> SO YES, MY HUSBAND CHASTAIN
FOUND THESE, HARD TO DESCRIBE
BUT BASICALLY TRAFFIC TONE --